China is on a war footing unverified
video on social media shows streets in
Wuhan where the virus originated being
sprayed with disinfectant but questions
linger over how China's government is
dealing with this invisible enemy few
countries can marshal the resources now
a China's disposal and that's the thrust
of the narrative on state control
television but hospitals are swamped
with an acute shortage of beds
gymnasiums and sports stadiums have been
turned into temporary medical centers to
cope with demand on Thursday the death
toll reached 565 the latest infections
included a newborn baby but China's
government says the number of virus
victims who are recovering is also
increasing here in Hong Kong the fear of
catching this virus appears to be more
contagious than the virus itself on
Thursday morning there were reports of
panic buying in some local supermarkets
with shelves being cleared of rice and
other staples forcing the Hong Kong
government to say there's no need to
worry there's plenty of food but there
are not plenty of face masks those that
are on sale costs three times what they
did before the crisis began people we
spoke to don't understand why the
government isn't providing them for free
there are many poor people they have to
queue up to buy to mass and I think the
government should do more on that to
solve the problem they are not doing
enough because they did not plan ahead
to press AC mass for the citizens yeah
so now the prices for the
is like going up the day after the Hong
Kong government announced it would soon
begin isolating all arrivals from the
mainland it remains unclear how that
will happen the two options appear to be
self isolation or being placed in
holiday camps converted to quarantine
centers in Hong Kong a luxury cruise
liner the second in Asia with infected
passengers is now a floating quarantine
center as medical teams continue
screening the 3,600 passengers and crew
the authorities are also appealing to
passengers who were on a previous voyage
to get in touch
fearing thousands more may have been
exposed to the virus Adrian Brown al
jazeera Hong Kong